Speaker 1: All right. This one I hope you're
sitting down for, or at least braced or attached
to something, because this is like nothing I have
ever seen. Just when it seems as though there is
nowhere else to go, there is no place to hide
for Donald Trump. Now that this audio tape has
come out where Trump is clearly heard shuffling
papers and saying, these are secret documents,
these are classified documents, I can't show
you this stuff. I shouldn't be showing you this
stuff. Trump was interviewed yesterday after
his speech in New Hampshire by the publication
Semaphore. And Trump's new claim is he wasn't
actually holding up any documents. It was just
like golf related documents. Golf are these
you can hear him shuffling papers. He's saying
these are secret documents. But there weren't
actually any documents. He was just playing it
up. Look at this article. This is by Shelby
Talcott for Semaphore. It was bravado. Trump
says he wasn't holding up classified documents
in the 2021 meeting referred to on the tape.
Look at these quotes. I would say it was bravado.
If you want to know the truth, it was bravado,
Trump said in an interview aboard his plane with
Semaphore and ABC News. I was talking and just
holding up papers and talking about them, but
I had no documents. I didn't have any documents
delayed. The latest comment suggested a new
potential legal argument from Trump that he
was overselling the material he was showing
to an aide and people working on a biography
of Mark Meadows in a recording quote, I just
held up a whole pile of my desk is loaded up
with papers. I have papers from 25 different
things, he said, adding he kept relevant news
articles about topics like Iran on hand. At one
point, Trump gestured to the seat next to him.
On the plane were a stack of various papers,
newspapers, copies of his speech, printouts of
article set. He grabbed some from the pile and
placed them in front of him, moving the round,
moving them around as he spoke and offering up a
physical reenactment of what he said was occurring
on the audio tape. Did I use the word plans? What
I'm referring to is magazines, newspapers, plans
of buildings. I had plans of buildings, you know,
building plans. I had plans for a golf course.
Asked if he had any regrets about his handling of
classified documents, Trump said, No, no, I have
no regrets. I didn't have a classified document.
There was no classified document on my desk.
Wow. This is like nothing I've ever seen or heard
of. Here's the new position. Yes, Trump does refer
to documents on the audio recording. Yes, You hear
papers shuffling around? Yes, there were papers on
Trump's desk. And yes, Trump uses the word plans,
but these were not classified plans to attack
Iran. These were golf course plans for for a golf
course Trump plan to build. And he was just trying
to impress the people around him. Now, of course,
the problem is there are witnesses who have
testified that these really were documents related
to military plans and defense information. That's
a little bit of a problem. That may be a problem
if Trump tries to use this argument in court.
And of course, the other problem is that this
is explanation number seven or eight for the
exact same thing. There were classified
documents, but they were declassified. Oh,
there were classified documents, but I had
the right to have them. And they are de facto
declassified just by virtue of me having them. Oh,
there were no documents at all. There were papers,
but they weren't classified documents. There
were classified documents. But I didn't take
them. The FBI planted them, or there might have
been some documents in boxes along with clothes
and momentos, as these people call them. I don't
know why they say momentos instead of the word
mementos. They just make up words. I don't
know, but it's just completely crazy. Now,
I want to add one other commentary here, and I
think that this is an important thing to mention.
There are some people on the revolutionary
left. I know that some people call them
tanks. I'm trying to be as least pejorative
as possible. The sort of like pro-Putin left,
the revolutionary left, the folks who like Maduro
in Venezuela or Castro or these types of folks,
there are some on the revolutionary left who
are saying this is I'm not even going to name
names. This is this entire leaked audio recording
story is another example of the corporate media
ignoring the good things about Trump. These plans
to attack Iran. Trump didn't want to attack Iran.
I got a few emails about this from revolutionary
lefties saying, David, why won't you be honest
and tell the real story? The real story is the
media hates Trump because when he was given that
plan to attack Iran, he didn't want to do it.
Now there's a whole bunch of different things
that could be said, including that presidents are
presented with every option all the time. And the
idea that someone was pushing him to attack Iran
and he didn't want to do it, we don't even know
that to be true. But you have to remember, Trump
has no idea what he's for or against. He might be
for or against attacking Iran today. He might have
been for or against attacking Iran on the day that
he was presented with those plans or on the day
that he showed someone. It doesn't matter. Trump
doesn't know anything about Iran. He doesn't know
anything about foreign policy. It is irrelevant
to whether Trump committed the crimes for which
he's been arrested, whether on that day or on
the day before or on the day after he wanted
to attack Iran or not. And the revolutionary
leftists who are saying there's no story here
other than Trump really was against wars and
he was against war with Iran. You are just flat
out wrong. That is not the story here. The story
here is they've got Trump dead to rights on an
audio recording committing the exact crimes that
he's been charged for. Now, what is his lawyer
saying about it? Let's talk about that next.